i'd like to announce my new book beyond
order 12 more rules for life
unlike my previous book beyond order
explores as its overarching theme
how the dangers of too much security and
control might be profitably avoided
because what we understand is
insufficient we need to keep one foot
within order
while stretching the other tentatively
into the beyond
i hope that people find this book as
helpful personally
as they seem to have found the first set
of 12 rules
[Music]
i'm pleased to have with me today mr
stephen fry
who's been described by more than one of
his compatriots as a national treasure
if you want to develop a quick
inferiority complex i would recommend
going
and reading steven's wikipedia page
he's a prolific actor screenwriter
playwright
journalist poet intellectual comedian
television presenter advertisement
presenter
magazine author autobiographist
um it's it's a remarkable body of
achievement and
an and an intellectual figure in his own
right who's known at least in part for
his
discussions with uh richard dawkins and
christopher hitchens and
and the humanist atheists and it's
partly for that reason that i wanted to
talk to him i met stephen
much to my pleasure during the monk
debates in toronto about
three years ago when we discussed
political correctness which is one of
the things i want to
talk about and touch upon today but
mostly i'm interested in talking to him
about
the relationship between narrative and
empiricism and rationalism and so thank
you very much for agreeing to talk to me
my pleasure lovely to be here so let me
ask you
and and then we'll we'll go forward
formally
um what do you think we would be best
what do you think would have the
greatest impact with regards to our
conversation
as far as you're concerned i mean there
must have been a reason that you
some reason apart from just being
agreeable
to to do this what do you think we might
be able to accomplish
well uniquely it's it's a little like um
that monk debate we we
shared a platform with um it's really
because
i'm i'm so tired and distressed and
worried by the
the the great physio that has opened up
the culture wars whatever we like to
call it
the assumption that um that there is
your friends and your enemy and no
ground in between no commonality of
no cohesion of viewpoint no shared
things that can happen between people
who apparently represent different ways
of looking at the world or different
ways of trying to organize the world or
whatever it might be
and the very fact that i knew some
friends of mine who disapproved of you
um would would think i was doing
something wrong by associating with you
and and uh i
i hope our debate showed that that
wasn't the case and i felt this would
take that further forward too um
i i do i do think the you know the last
best hope for our
society in whichever way you want to
look at whether you want to look at it
as
some version of the west being able to
stand up to the
pressures put upon it by china and
russia and other countries that are
less interested in liberality in
economics and in the traditional
political sense of liberality or
kind of open society whatever you want
to call it
um that that if we continue to fracture
and we continue to find enemies amongst
our own kind
so much um then really
it's a very very sad look at i mean
i'm hardly the first person to say this
but and and i think you are
you know a very interesting um thinker
and
writer and and talker um
but it's it's clear that there are many
who would really admire you and like you
and follow you
uh who with whom i would have less in
common than perhaps with you
um i think on both sides if you want to
call them sides
it's very easy to be a bit lacks about
disavowing people
who like one but whom one doesn't like
if you see what i mean
uh it's it's it's so flattering to the
ego to have followers
to have people say you're great i love
the things you say
that um it's quite hard to say no but
you've misunderstood me that's not what
i meant that's not what i meant at all
to quote elliot
so obviously i've spent some time
pointing out what i regard as the
excesses of the
radical left i've certainly spent no
shortage of time pointing out the
excesses of the radical right in my
classes
particularly but i'm not publicly known
for that specifically it's
it's my resistance or or
yeah my resistance to certain maneuvers
on the side of the radical
left that propelled me into the public
eye
um i've thought for a long while that
the only people who can probably control
the excesses of the radical left
are people who are in the moderate left
not people on the right or on the
extreme right
they're out of the argument to begin
with and it it it's this is
associated in some sense the difficulty
of this is
in some sense the difficulty that you
just described
if people have an affiliation with you
then it's much more difficult to
differentiate
perhaps where you should and so
perhaps you see on the left the moderate
leftists
and then the more extreme leftists but
the
left extreme leftists are also on the
left
and they're friends of a type and
drawing that line
is extraordinarily difficult and that's
actually why at least part of the reason
why
i'm leery of any attempts to
restrict free speech because in those
cases of difficult differentiation the
only
possible solution we have is
dialogue about the problem about exactly
where to draw the line
because otherwise we can't no one knows
how
and i guess it's because extremism also
also exists in degrees
and so you say where do you stop and
well that's very very difficult to say
especially among those who think like
you except for certain
exceptions yes this is
this is very true and it's a sort of
basic philosophical point isn't it that
you can draw lines um between what is
reasonable and they can be very narrow
lines but if you keep
drawing them out they become extreme so
for example you can have a
what some people might regard as a
reasonable age for the termination of a
pregnancy due to some
you know some issue but if you keep
adding days to it it then becomes
a serious problem and anything in that
nature of
uh of of differentiating and drawing
lines he's bound to
is bound to cause that to be a problem
and i i
however i'm less confident than you are
that
the left would be persuaded by someone
like me the hard left
the uh one wants to call it extreme left
or the radical
left wherever it is um and this may
sound a bit like a bit of
boo-hooing which is very easy to do but
if you're a soft liberal as i
think of myself i can't find any other
designation but that sort of thing
the centrist um these are insults to the
left i mean in english politics recently
for example centrist was
the boo word of the corbinistas the the
the more socialist end of the labour
party a party i've been a member of
since
since i could vote and i i felt very
very very much um buffeted about and
despised
for my oh dear but really and oh must we
you know i it's very
you know i do think of myself as a sort
of cardigan
slippered old fool who is loathed on
both sides
and and it is of course historically
true that in the 1930s which is the
decade we always go back to when we
were very worried about the the
direction we're traveling in now
um the communists and and
the nazis both were absolutely on one
mind when it came to people like me
jewish semi-intellectual soft liberals
who
you know who won't oh no but shush um
because we didn't have any positivity
any certainty we didn't turn
we didn't you know it's
and as i say i know it sounds like i'm
sort of taking on a victim status here
that oh poor liberals
because after all we've ruled the world
for 200 years and
part of the political and cultural
argument in the world at the moment is
that the liberal
project the enlightenment project if you
want to call it that
has failed um i would say we've
cooperatively guided the world
because i think ruled is the wrong term
tyrant's rule and and it's a really
important distinction because
the power is grounded in the sovereignty
of the people and
imperfect as that may be it's more
grounded in the sovereignty of the
people than any other system we've ever
managed to whip up
so i mean it's it's difficult also
because it
central it's difficult to make centrism
dramatic and romantic and it's much
easier to make extremism dramatic and
romantic and that's one of its primary
attractions and
that attraction should not be
underestimated and it's partly why i'm
so interested in talking to you because
you are this incredible dramatist you
have this unbelievable talent that
manifests itself
in a manner that i thought i was reading
your weak wikipedia biography in some
detail
and it requires that i thought if you
want to give yourself an inferiority
complex quickly
going through your wikipedia entry is a
very good way of doing that i mean you
have
50 films and like 40 tv shows and
five novels and seven autobiographies
and a
career in comedy that was absolutely
outstanding that would have been
uh a lifetime achievement in and of
itself and a
whole variety of honorary doctorates and
and you have an intellectual end that's
not trivial as well because you were
involved with hitchens and dawkins and
the
horsemen of the um of the atheist
movement
yeah and i want to really want to talk
to you about that too because
i especially am interested in your
opinions because
of all those people you're the one that
has the most connection with
you with with uh with drama
and literature and fiction and you you
you just published a couple of books
mythos
um heroism heroes heroes
and there's there's a third one in that
trilogy it just escapes my mind
troy and so you're obviously
extraordinarily sensitive to the
power and necessity of
literary accounts but then you're also a
humanistic atheist and
that's very i'm very curious about that
i mean someone like dawkins he's so
rational
that i think for him and i don't know if
this is fair it might be a
bit of a of a stereotype but it'll do
for rhetorical purposes
he's not gripped by drama
in the same way you are and there's a
truth in drama that's not trivial and
that truth
is allied with religious truth so i want
to go there
too i can't speak for richard it's just
been his 80th birthday so we wish him
happy birthday and he's he's not the the
shrill
beast of of atheism that some people
regard him as but
i won't speak for him obviously but but
what i would say is that yes you're
right he's a rationalist and i don't
think i am i think
i'm an empiricist and i i think
that's part of my love of drama and myth
and story and literature
and history even is these are all to do
with experience with human experience
the register of human experience
of of testing an idea against what
actually happens and how
people actually behave rather than
uh devising a system of reason
um and it's not the reason when
empiricism are always absolutely opposed
but they sometimes are
and in the in in the history of science
they have been you know you could argue
that
pascal was a rationalist and and uh
newton was an empiricist for all his
you know great mathematics and so on he
actually took a piece of cardboard and
punched a hole in it
which is something that a rationalist
probably wouldn't wouldn't do
so it's experimenting in the crucible of
human activity and observing what people
say and hear
these are the things comedians do all
the time it's the comic
it's it's the comic mode is to
hear somebody say something grand and
then say yes but
g.k chesterton is a perfect example of
that now he was
he was certainly no atheist he was a
very religious man indeed
and and a great hero of the catholic
church and some people even
believe he should be if not beatified
even sanctified but
um he he was a huge influence on me as a
teenager growing up because i read his
essays
and here's an example uh um
he read he he opens an essay by saying
i read in the newspaper the other day
this following sentence
at the trumpet call of ibsen and shaw
modern woman rises to take her place in
society
and i thought to myself this is very
good news very encouraging i wonder if
it's true
let's see now who's a modern woman oh
mrs buttons she comes in to clean every
tuesday and every thursday she lives in
clapham
she comes on the omnibus and she scrubs
the floors
and she has three children and if i say
to myself at the trumpet call of ibsen
and shaw mrs buttons rises to take her
place in society
i realize the sentence is not only
nonsense it's pernicious nonsense
and and that's a sort of
almost comical example really of saying
you don't trust an abstract statement
you do not trust
someone saying a plus a equals 2a
because there is no such thing in the
universe as a
and although we're all capable of doing
substitutional
metaphorising or algebra as it were with
ideas
the fact is it's much better to say one
thing of something that is real that we
know plus another thing of something
that is real that we know and have
experienced
is two of those things once you start
abstracting
and and and that's what rationalism
often is
it's it's going off on an algebraic
journey
which can produce beautiful thoughts and
ideas and beautiful schemes
but for me it is beating that out on the
anvil of
human experience is the absolute key and
it's a non-intellectual tradition
empiricism and uh i think
we're in danger of losing it in a way
because okay i want to unpack
three things that you that you just said
that are very very complicated
so the first thing you did was draw a
distinction between rationalism and
empiricism
and you associated dawkins more with
rationalism and yourself more with
empiricism yes
entirely but yeah no no no fair enough
just as example and
and you you did that in an attempt to
also describe
um the effect or influence or
consequence or reason
for your interest in drama or for the
fact that
drama grips you so i want to start with
the distinction between human
or between empiricism and rationalism so
everyone listening understands so
walk us through that first well
empiricism is
is um is an intellectual tradition of
of using experience or trial and error
or
or experiment to to prove or disprove
or to investigate an idea
so if you have an idea i mean a perfect
example is
in the 18th and 19th century a lot of
women were dying
of childbirth at childbirth appalling
deaths what we would now call septicemia
the babies and the mothers were dying
and nobody knew why
because there was no germ theory nobody
had an idea that there were these
tiny things that could infect our
systems
so people tried to reason and they said
well
maybe it's the smell because it's a bad
smell and there was a miasma theory
um and other people just
said it was god or other people said
that it was some moral quality on the
part of the women
um and but a man called semovice in
in hungary ignacimo vice um tried
lots of different experiments he he he
chose
a certain number of people to do
different things on what we now call
cohort testing you know raw not quite
random double blind testing such as used
as in meds in medicine
to prove the efficacy of something but
eventually
he he got a group of medical students
who were attending on these births
to wash their hands before doing it it
was an almost random thing to do
and suddenly the death rate dropped i
mean absolutely plummeted
and the reward for semmelweis he was
sent to a madhouse
because nobody believed where he died
because the rationalist said there's no
reason that that could be
that could be right but a true
empiricist would say it almost doesn't
matter what the reason is
the fact is it's repeatable and
verifiable
and and even not understanding because
it took later till and
pasteur and microscopes could show what
the process was
he he actually did end up in a you know
and he's a hero man i ran actually went
to budapest to go to the
ignac several vice museum in in buddha
just to sort of pay homage to this
remarkable man and i mean it's a bit
unfair on the doctors they had no
reason to know if you like but that's
the point they had no reason to know
an example we all deal with empiricism
which can be very annoying
is in insurance what's called actuarial
tables or actuaries
are people in insurance companies who
look at the statistics
and if they discovered that when your
name is jordan you are 10
more likely to have a car crash you
would pay 10
more of premium on your insurance and
it's no good you saying but why they
would just say those
are the odds that's the empirical truth
that's the
epidemiology of accidents if you like is
that people call jordan or more famously
of course actors pay more
and you can then try and look for a
reason and that's a very valuable thing
to do of course we all want to know the
reason
but um sometimes i think there is a
beauty
in testing and looking and seeing and
trying things out and experimenting
it's not a discard reason that the two
go together in
yes finding out the truth so so how do
you associate that with
your interest in in literature and your
clear recognition that
the the dramatic end of existence
is valuable well i suppose it's
i mean in an obvious way uh all
literature people literature snobs i
might say
uh will look at politics i mean all
through my life i've looked at people
like i don't know margaret thatcher
or indeed on the other side gordon brown
and thought if only they read
shakespeare
why why why do people read books of
political philosophy and
and and books on this being a good idea
on
you know how parliamentary history
without actually
reading about how humans behave and
seeing
how evil and good are played out in in
drama
because i think not just like teacher
but ceremony and ritual
are extremely important in in
understanding
uh everything um and you don't have to
be religious
to to believe in ritual i love liturgy i
love church liturgy i am absolutely
passionate about hymns and
and psalms and and the eucharist
and and the language of it you know the
the um
the outward invisible sign of an inward
invisible grace is one of the most
beautiful phrases
uh i think ever written in the in the in
the in the book of the eucharist of the
episcopalian church as americans call it
all the anglican churches we call it and
and there are
magnificent um shortcuts available
if if you look at ceremony and the
dramatization
of of human issues rather than
attempting
to abstract some essence from them
some truth that you can say that is
applicable to all
it's in the sense we're all children who
have to be shown puppets before we
understand
do you know what i mean does that mean
yes yeah
i've stopped sorry no no no no well it's
just
it's just stopped and and made me think
i mean
the reason i got in interested in
religious thinking
i went down the pathway that you're
describing
i mean that's why i got interested in
religious thinking
because from a psychological perspective
i mean
the first thing that i realized and i
believe this is
what you just pointed out is that there
are truths
embedded in fiction
for example or in spectacle
ritual drama and
well then you ask well what is it though
those are attractive and they're
entertaining and they
they automatically engage our interest
and but way more than that they're also
that which culture centers itself around
greek tragedy for example which seemed
to be integrally associated with the
elusive greek mystery is something that
we
we know very little about unfortunately
but
for me and and i was influenced by carl
jung in this
mode of thinking culture is nested
inside a narrative
structure by by necessity i even believe
that science is nested inside an
uh a narrative structure because the
narrative structure is what makes the
science
practically applicable and useful yes
what what else is the standard model
but another way of saying a a narrative
structure
the standard model is just that and that
is the basis of physics today isn't it
it's a story well well in the
the idea that we have that science is a
useful endeavor the fact that we're
looking to the material world for
redemption
that's all part of the narrative and i
was absolutely staggered by jung's
analysis of the emergence of science out
of alchemy
and his notion was that the alchemical
tradition was a 2
000 year old dream a narrative dream
counter position to christianity with
its emphasis on abstracted spirituality
suggesting that what we lacked could be
found
in the depths of the material world and
that was
and and so there was this motivational
dream
that if we paid enough attention to the
transformations of matter we could find
that which would confer upon us
uh eternal life infinite health and
wealth
and jung's point was well until that
dream was in place
there would be no motivation to
undertake the process of the painstaking
analysis of the material world that
didn't produce any immediate
gratification
and it took thousands of years for that
idea to assemble
itself with enough force so that we
could start to have scientists
so the narrative was operative thousands
of years before the
before the before the technical process
was instituted and it laid the
groundwork for it
and maybe also took that time for
uh for the brain of humans
uh if you believe julian james and and i
i kind of do in
in a metaphorical way i don't if you
know his book
yes i'm sure you do yeah um that
maybe you know our brains weren't even
capable of processing in that way
around the time of uh between language
and writing the
you know that sort of time uh we we were
finding ways of of describing the world
in the to the egyptian i believe i'm
right in saying this is the derivation
el hamet the the magic became alchemy
uh which then became chemistry um and
and it became drilled down into a an
investigation but
first you had to believe that there was
a ahem it was a magic inside
everything inside substance um to which
we could
be tuned and yes um right a redemptive
magic
yes if you like and this is not to
repudiate science and numbers and
you know i'm a a very good friend of
mine who was a priest said
uh um you know physics is a theology
that makes
machines work and there's there's some
there's some sort of truth in that and i
i love for example the story i
i tell it in a footnote in mythos but
it's very very early on in
greek mythology um when the the first
the primal
the primal entities the primal deities
are uranus the sky or uranus
as children we love to call him um and
gaia the earth who mate the sky and the
earth mate is a common
theme in uh what they call a mithim
in lots of different myths as you can
imagine the sky and the earth
mate and they produce whatever is in
between the zone
which we inhabit between sky and earth
and that next generation are called
the titans of of course but uh and
and there's the the famous story of the
the birth of zeus
his father the titan eats all his
children and
the mother raya is determined that the
last child zeus shouldn't be eaten
so she goes and gets a rock um from
close by where where where she she lives
on montauk authoris and
uh she covers it in swaddling and hides
it under her legs and then makes the
child makes the noise of childbirth
and kronos the the titan comes thinks
it's a new baby swallows it whole
um and the actual baby is then born on
crete and becomes zeus the
leader of the next generation of gods
but the stone she takes is from
magnesium
in in greece which is near thessaly
and it's a stone that the greeks have
noticed had a very
extraordinary property which is the most
interesting property that any
object can have on earth and is very
rare and that it can attract things
remotely from a distance that that
without there being a
physical force connecting them
apparently a piece of fluff or paper
could fly towards this
stone from magnesium and so
stones that have this property are named
after that part of the world
they're called magnetites and from
magnetites we get magnets
and the story of magnets and how magnets
were then joined
by thompson and faraday and others to to
make him
uh and maxwell to to to to make the
electromotive force that
allows you and me to talk the way we do
and to use that
action at a distance which science is
brilliant
at turning into extraordinary magical
machines
the greek for at a distance is tele so
it's tele communication telephone
television and teleporting anything that
goes from one distant telegrams and tele
you know and so on telegraphs um
and and that is the and and gravity is
the same thing
something moves and there's nothing
between it and and it it makes us
thrill and science can do that um
and what we've never found a way to do
is is
or at least what we try to find a bit is
to do the same with
with our fellow people but our fellow
people are
you know the world is surprisingly
stable there's magnet
magnets around the place and there's
gold and there's stuff and you dig it up
and
and you can do terrible damage to it as
we have
but we have moved from from small groups
clans to tribes to nations
to this strange myth of the nation and
so on and
the individuals within it um are much
less controllable than the objects
around us and yet we can control those
objects so superbly that it gives us an
idea
that we that we have a special place and
a special power
um and it's i suppose
really what we want to do is to
reconnect ourselves
to the same motive forces that that
are thrilling like magnetism and
electricity that exist in
in also all throughout nature that we
look at them you know
which of us can't honestly almost sob
with joy when spring happens
and you see that once again these leaves
are being pushed out of dead branches
and
blossoms there and insects are flying
towards them there's this
fantastic process going on and
somehow we've allowed ourselves to feel
outside it as if we are special we've
given ourselves a godlike status
which is very dangerous i think and very
foolish
um and the more i look
back the more confidence i have in
looking forward i suppose that's one of
the other reasons i love
myth so much so okay so all right so um
you you described yourself as an
empiricist and then you talked about
you started to talk about the attraction
that the mythological and and narrative
world has for you and and
some of the reasons for that and then
but you also just
differentiated between you and dawkins
to some degree
and impair and so while i'm curious
about why oh but i mean he's
i mean i i'm as i said i can't speak for
him but you use the word wrestling and i
understand
originally and and i don't i don't have
any particular points of disagreement
with him i'm really fond of him he's a
friend and i i only feel
sorry sometimes that uh and this is a
cheap
point um it's you know
where most of it's a bit fed up with
this attitude that it's all about
presentation
and i could argue that richard's
presentation his passion is real
his love of science is real his love of
the joy and the wonder of discovery
is real he's written books on wonder
which is a huge and
marvelous and much under explored
human quality and a primary religious
instinct yes
and and yet science has shown us and it
really can
just can't be contested that we are part
of a continuum of life
dna demonstrates this the dna we share
not just with
our close um uh uh ape-like and and
and other mammals but also with plants
and flowers that also have dna
and as we know soda viruses and
and um and yet or rna
and um and yet
i don't think i think it's fair to say
that blackbirds don't look at the sunset
and go my god that's so beautiful did
you see that
i want to paint it i want to remember it
how is it
you know this this sense of literally of
marveling
it's the only world we know when we're
born
we don't think of course there are 70
other globes with much better sunsets
this is the only thing we've ever seen
and yet it staggers us it surprises us
we're surprised by what is the case
to use the phrase that wittgenstein
loved you know the case
is everything around us and
we don't know another one um and yet
we go wow why should we go wow
what is absolutely ordinary there
there must be a a reason i suspect that
we are
astonished by the everyday
by the fact of what we see when we look
out of the window or when we go
for a walk we're astonished by buds and
grass and rabbits and
sky and clouds and these things aren't
well we're astonished
we're astonished by what we want to
imitate yeah
yeah yeah and i mean i've thought about
that idea for a long time
it's not a casual response to your
question
well the son is a hero
the son is the hero that fights the
darkness at night and rises anew in the
morning
the sun is associated with consciousness
yeah
and we have to imitate the hero and we
see what we have to imitate everywhere
and it reduces us to a state of
of awe and awe is an invitation to
imitate
and and imagine so you you see what you
are not yet but what you could be
and you need to see that because you
need to turn into what you
could be because what you are is not
sufficient to redeem you
well i see that from a jungian point of
view but i'm
and joseph camberley sort of way too but
in terms of the way myths
and then religions developed the idea of
imitating these symbols of this
of complete power and creation like the
sun whether it's
raw or whether it's apollo or any other
deity or
sense of solar greatness
you are supposed to supplicate or
sacrifice to or
acknowledge your weakness too but we
could look at sacrifice
look at sacrifice that's a great that's
a great inward point
so i ask my students especially the
children of first generation immigrants
what did your parents sacrifice to put
you here
and they can answer that instantly and
sacrifice like we look at
sac ancient sacrifice and we think about
about it as something
primordial or even detestable especially
in its more extreme forms and no wonder
but we had to act out sacrifice
before we could psychologize it and
understand it
and what we learned and this is
absolutely crucial this issue of
sacrifice what we learned was that if we
gave up something
that we valued in the present and so
that could be a false idol that's one
way of thinking about it
if we gave up something in the present
that we valued
the future would improve we learned that
we could bargain
with reality itself by
sacrificing counterproductive values
to move ahead and so we acted that out
long before we could
make it into a psychological uh uh
truism
and so it's there is that supplication
element but
but it's also the case that you should
be prostate in some
prostrate in some sense in front of
what's ultimately ideal because
otherwise you don't have the proper
humility
um yes i i mean i i see what you're
saying again
it makes rational sense but then the
empiricist in me says well okay
i'm the mother of some of those children
in mexico who are being slaughtered
uh to the gods in order to make the
harvest better and
lo and behold it doesn't work because
there is no causal relation between
sacrificing children
on a pyramid in in texas and
the harvest improving in fact there may
well be an earthquake the next day and
more people die
that very often did happen in whole
civilizations mayan and mexican and
others
disappeared and the more they were
threatened the more they sacrificed
and the less use it was so there was no
it may have had a psychological purpose
that i don't know i mean it seems to me
the psychology of sacrificing your
children
or even your very rare cattle uh upon
which you may depend for a year to eat
uh to gods uh who will apparently
placate you by making a better harvest
or
not send a tidal wave this year that
will destroy the port and all the other
things that our ancestors found in the
contingent
world in which they an unstable world in
which they lived
so i i can understand why a 19th century
figure like frasier or
you know in the golden bow or or or like
mary mccarthy or
young or um joseph campbell can can make
wonderful
myths out of myths
they're telling a story about stories
and telling us what they
mean well i i i don't refute it
i repudiate i i i allow myself to
believe no actually
yes it's it's all very well and you can
you can build a very nice theory
about what these myths mean and who
these hero are
what these quests are and how they're
only seven stories
and yes but again the the stand-up
comedian type empirici
system he says okay so i'm a small roman
person uh under those circumstances and
what is this really meaning to me i'm
sorry no
i've i've got as wordsworth put it it's
getting and spending and doing and
having children and
looking and hoping life gets better and
enjoying life with my friends but
to erect it into a spiritual language
and a
theater of of of uh
of human meaning uh is
delightful and it but i think we have to
recognize that it's a game
to some extent it may be it may indeed
be true i mean i
you know i'm not saying this to to to
demolish your argument but i'm saying
it's
yes but you know in terms of the butts
are important
yeah and the skepticism is necessary
because
you don't want to leave anything
standing except that which can't
survive the onslaught yes and there's no
doubt that
there's no doubt that the sacrificial
idea can go dreadfully wrong
and i i but i would say that that's in
the nature of
of the attempt because it's obviously
the case that sometimes
you make sacrifices towards a certain
end which is
clearly an attempt to bargain with the
future as if it's something that
can be bargained with yes but sometimes
that works and sometimes it doesn't
and later after that the the cultures of
sacrifice around the world
there came a new uh system where it was
the gods who sacrificed
themselves which is like the christian
myth or the many of the
dying and re re reborn kings in in
various myths that
that james fraser in particular wrote
about and um
their christ ransomed himself uh as it
was so so
so suddenly it's it's as if humans said
this sacrifice is getting us nowhere if
god really loves us
he would sacrifice himself or herself
for us
and that is one of the one of the
meanings
of the um the incarnation and then
the the the the christian story is it
not uh and it's not unique in any way
there are there are many other stories
of
of divine divine figures uh being
sacrificed to save the society
that they in which they they make
themselves flash
you sacrifice your short-term impulses
for the long-term good
i suppose that's one way of thinking
about the discovery of the future
that speaks very well to your books that
speaks very well to your books because
you know underlying both your excellent
books of you know
rules and behavior is that that i don't
mean this in a bad way the the simple
truth of
of deferred pleasure being something
that seems to be or deferred advantage
being something that seems to have gone
out of human culture lately
that we you know we're all a bit verruck
assault i want it i want it now
you know and um as you said about
sacrifices
you you you suffer or you
uh you find you know in in some way you
uh
you defer um what what what pleasure
might
positively be yours now in order to have
a future advantage yeah
right and and then we have an immense
discussion that lasts forever about
what that optimal future advantage is
and that that's part of this religious
investigation because you might say
and this is something that's manifesting
itself in christianity which is
well we're trying to produce something
better in the future and so then you ask
yourself what does better mean
that's the first question and what the f
what does the future mean
those need to be answered and then the
net the final question is well what's
the most appropriate sacrifice and
so you get an extreme version of that in
christianity hence its narrative power
which is
well you sacrifice the most valuable
possible thing
for what's of ultimate eternal value
that's the underlying structure and in
some sense it it hits a limit
because it's god himself who sacrificed
and the purpose of the sacrifice is the
is the establishment the redemption of
humanity and the establishment of
of the kingdom of heaven eternally so
that there isn't anything better than
that by definition
well i i know if i was to raise altuser
or a marxist view of this
and say that it's about the power over
the people which basically denies them
any kind of pleasure now
on a promise which is unprovable of a
future glorification of some kind or
another
either for their children or for
themselves in a heaven
uh whose direction they can't point to
um and then not just altocerin
marxists of course many many secularists
and atheists like myself have said you
know there there is a
there is a story to be told about
religion uh basically
stopping ordinary citizens from having
any say
um in in in their life and their world
they are told what the truth is they are
told where power
comes from and where it resides and they
are told that their poverty
and their subservience and their
sacrifice are for the greater good and
they
they must take that authority on its
word
and the meaning of the enlightenment was
the the
throwing off of those shackles of
aristotelian ecclesiasticism
which constantly laid down these these
categories of authority
um and people began to question them
and say i wonder because i think we
might just talk about
is i know it interests you and and there
are people written quite a few books
about it lately
is the distinction between a hierarchy
and a network
um in terms of how you order society
that
and these religions and these sacrifices
all came in hierarchical societies
rather it seems
in in ones that might be called
networked
nodal or some other word i know neil
ferguson has written about this isn't he
in the book that i can't remember its
title it's got the word
tower in it but
it's one of the objections people have
to the modern
liberally produced world is that
morality is
relative and that hierarchies are
toppled
and that power and authority are no
longer seen to reside
in something some agree you know the
curtain is pulled away and the wizard of
oz is revealed to be
nothing a silly foolish snake oil
salesman
and the answer lies within ourselves
okay so i have to stop you there because
i can't answer i won't be able to ask
this question
there's so many things that you're
saying that i want to ask about i
they're they're
they're there's okay so
with regards to the idea of the opiate
of the masses
okay well the first thing we might note
i think reasonably is that
marxism is the methamphetamine of the
masses and whatever
whatever flaws judeo-christianity might
have had
in terms of its corruption was certainly
matched by the instantaneous corruption
yes but the fact that a marxist has a
critique of religion does not mean that
it
falls because marxism itself falls
okay so that there's a second question
there and so the second question would
be something like
is the corruption of the church that you
described
intrinsic to the nature of the church
and its doctrine or
is it the corruption of something that's
valuable
now let me make two arguments for that
one
is that the corruption is intrinsic and
the whole thing should be just dispensed
with
and i would say that that's the
perspective of the four horsemen
fundamentally
um yeah and it might
and of religious people themselves i
mean thomas cranmer who wrote the
the prayer book uh during the
reformation there's a great phrase in it
there was not anything by the wit of man
devised that hath not been in time
in part or in whole corrupted
absolutely and and i think that's also
an existential truth
i mean you just talked about kronos
kronos devours his sons well kronos is
the archetypal tyrant and he's also
time and both time and the archetypal
tyrant devour their own sons so if
you're a tyrannical father
or a tyrannical statesman instead of
encouraging the development
of the young people in your charge
you'll crush them and
destroy them he also castrated his own
father
with so that's i would say that that's
that's uh
that's something like demolition of the
utility of tradition
i mean in in the egyptian in egyptian
mythology you see horus who's the son
fundamentally both the actual son the
heavenly son
and the son and osiris and for the
egyptians horus and osiris had to rule
simultaneously
so horus didn't castrate osiris he
rescued him from the underworld
and joined with them so that the
tradition which was represented by
osiris which had a chronos-like element
because it was tyrannical and
destruction
destructive had to be allied with
horus who was essentially something like
i would say something like empirical
attention
it's some because the symbol is the eye
and so it was like
alert tradition and that's different
than the castration of the father that's
the rescuing of the father from the
underworld when he becomes corrupt and
senile
now when you just published mythos we
refer to this mythos
heroes and troy and so i would say and
you tell me if i'm wrong but from the
outside
it looks to me like you're involved in
an uh
philosophical archaeological expedition
to find things of value in the past and
to bring them forward into the future
and and that's what i am trying to do at
least for me
i would say with regards to christianity
it's like i know the critiques and i
understand the critiques and it's not
like i'm not
what would you call um sensitive to
their finer
points it is an open question right
how much of the tradition look i know in
britain right now
there are people who say that flying the
flag is an imperialist
act and so what are they asking they're
saying well is our tradition so
irredeemably corrupt that we have to
abandon it wholeheartedly
i can speak to this very directly
because it it's
something i find very very interesting
again it's a so much of it is historical
ignorance
um for those who who are obsessed with
the flag and the politicians who want to
to fly the i would urge them to read
rudyard kipling
who is supposed to be uh in some
people's
eyes the poet and bard of british empire
of the raj that the spokesman for this
very thing
there is a scene in one of his
masterpieces stalking
co the book set in a school where a
politician
comes to the school to give a speech and
he has a flag and he
and the the school children
are outraged absolutely
horrified this takes place in
the second year of gladstone's five-year
premiership at the
absolute height of the british empire
the queen is on
the throne she's you know her crown and
her flag are fluttering all over the
world
and these boys are at this special
school which is actually a kind of
feeder for the british empire they're
all be sent out to fight in afghan wars
and in india and in the bir war later on
and and kipling describes how they die
but the idea to
them that anybody would dare to wave a
flag
and ask them to value it was so
disgusting
they could barely speak it's a very
extraordinary passage where he
describes their horror at this
politician
using the flag and claiming to own it
he makes the point that one's
relationship to one's country is
intensely private and it may be that one
has great love for it but
it's a love that is complex and
confounded with all kinds of
disappointment and hatred and
and fear and shame as well as love
and it is one's own thing but to fly it
and to wave it and to say that it means
this is
is a lie and an imposition on the
personal experience
of those boys in that story and i would
urge everyone to read that because
it comes from a surprising source it's
no accident that
the best writer you say the same about
burning it
is it the same kind because you you just
offered a balanced account because you
said well
if you're sensible let's say and and
that that your feelings for your country
so let's say your feelings for your
tradition or your regard for your
tradition
is a complex mix of of emotions from
uh abhorrence and shame and contempt to
love that entire
distribution okay that seems to me to be
appropriate and
i my sense is that that's expressed
mythologically
by two figures of tradition one the wise
king and the other
the evil tyrant and all cultures are a
meld of both
although to to a greater or lesser
degree
because you get pure forms of tyranny
and pure forms of
a benevolent rule okay hopefully i think
that's a reasonable proposition okay so
it's complex
but you're willing to accept that
complexity but what i and and
what i see and maybe this will tie us
back into the
political discussion that we sort of
started this off with
is that um in radical movements
radical critical movements and i think i
place the the
atheist horsemen in that category
there's no
the love is not there the respect is not
there
the the pointing out of the flaws is
there and the contempt is there
but the attempt that's not good enough
look if you read a piece of literature
you want to dismiss that which is no
longer relevant and
extract out that which is crucial that's
critical reading yeah it's but the
purpose isn't to dismiss
no fundamentally the purpose is to mine
no
and i would say another um another very
central piece of literature for me
higher literature than than kipling most
people would say is
is one of flaubert's um short stories
uh uh uh and cursed sampler simple heart
which is about a this poor peasant woman
felicity i think her name is
uh and that there's a scene in which she
kneels in front of a stained glass
window and and
this is where the parrot comes from that
julian barnes wrote about so brilliantly
in flaubert's parrot
but she's incredibly simple and
incredibly ignorant and
uneducated but also incredibly devout
and she kneels there with her her knees
are in
desperate pain because she spends her
whole life on them scrubbing floors
um and she sees this extraordinary
stained glass and flow bear is able to
describe
the incredible corruption and venality
that went into the spending of the money
on this spain stained glass and the
lives
of the corrupt priests who did it but
also showed the light
coming from her rather than from behind
the glass
it's a very holy moment and it's
anybody who dismisses religion would be
well to remember that devotion
and piety can be wonderful things as
well as terribly
brutal things and okay so i want to
understand the difference
right okay i'm going to read something
and forgive me no
i want to go here you're face to face
with god
bone cancer in children what's that
about how dare you
how dare you create a world where there
is such misery that's not our fault
it's utterly utterly evil why should i
respect a
capricious mean-minded stupid god who
creates a world so full of injustice and
pain
and then one more because the god who
created this universe if it was created
by god is quite clearly a maniac
other maniac ivan in the brothers
karamazov
yeah right right now it's in okay so
what happens in the brothers
karamazov is that ivan wins the argument
yeah
but elotia is the better person
completely so and we love
it yeah it's a book very interesting i
would urge everyone to read the brothers
karamazov because i do think it's a work
of genius
there's a lot about dostoevsky i really
dislike because of his influences
again people who don't understand
dostoyevsky think he's a champion of
right-wing
religiosity without understanding that
he went through an
extraordinary life experience to come to
where he did come
and that his novels show his full
understanding of all kinds of
different points of view but in terms of
the dialectic of
of of that issue about how how there can
be a god
i i mean i was answering a question that
i was asking i know and i'm not trying
i'm not clearly not trying to put you on
this side
my point is i don't believe there is
such a being but if there were and he
were
the kind of being that has been
worshipped
and described by various religions
around the world of monotheistic
religions
then i would have many bones to pick
with him um
but of course i don't believe there is
such a thing but the the argument from
evil as it's known is a is a very old
one and
it goes back through through the through
you know medieval religious figures as
well as
uh later humanists that this idea that
uh
it is it is very hard to square this
loving god who has uh knowledge of every
hair on our head
and adores us and um and adores little
kittens but
he also as i say bone cancer in in
in children but also life cycles of
insects that
whose whole aim is to burrow into the
eyes of children in africa
and and lay their eggs there and cause
blindness for those children i mean
you could quite easily picture a
universe in which there weren't such an
animal
and in which children were not sent
blind with pain and horror
by the various bugs and fungus fungi and
insects and viruses
in the world
there's a worm in africa that burrows
under the skin and it's
long worm and if you you can pull it out
with a pencil and wrap it but it breaks
it's fragile and then it gets infected
it's a terrible thing and
a doctor recently made it his life's
work to eradicate that and did it
successfully
yeah and so then i would so i read what
you wrote and
i mean i i take it very seriously and
and i
it wasn't i wasn't throwing it in your
face i brought it up actually because of
what you said about
flaubert's attitude you know because
what that lacks what your statement
lacks
is exactly what flo bear highlighted in
that woman on her knees and
and i'm not saying this is a simple
solution right it's and
and i would say so let's take the
argument you made there
and there's a there's a direction that
goes in that's nihilistic and resentful
and vengeful and angry and all
understandable
but to me counter it doesn't look to me
like there's anything good in it it
looks like it's entirely
counterproductive
it it it makes the problem it purports
to
uh have been generated by worse
so then the question is what's the
appropriate attitude
given that the argument you make is
actually an extraordinarily powerful
argument and
i don't know the answer to that but i
but i do know i think
that resentment and anger and even the
motive that would make you want to say
that to god himself
i think that's probably not helpful
even though it's so well
it i came to that with great difficulty
i mean i've had
my reasons to be resentful and angry
especially recently
and because i'm suffering a lot of pain
and
it makes me resentful and angry and
wanting to shake my fist
but i found upon intense consideration
that
there was nothing in that that didn't
make it worse and that therefore that
must be wrong
even though it's justifiable right i
completely understand and you must
remember that my response
was to a question i didn't see coming
and it was amused it was
because i don't believe in this god it's
not an issue i'm not really resentful
and angry about the fact that there's
evil in the world
i'm sorrowful very often and
i'm united in my admiration for the fact
and the real belief i have that most
people
fundamentally given this dysfunction or
this
deep trauma most people are so
good are so anxious to be good
are deontically good have a sense of
obligation
and and and drive in them to be better
than they
are i think that's that's one of the key
things
that i love about humanity is not just
that we are dissatisfied with things
that are
wrong and can be improved but with
ourselves we are dissatisfied and that
most of us
want to be better i i know that's true
of me all the time every time i go off
to sleep i think
how did i screw up tonight today how can
i be better tomorrow why am i so bad at
this
if only i could manage that in in moral
terms genuine moral terms
yes i think that's an extraordinarily
common experience
very much under noticed and
part of the reason as far as i can tell
that the talks that i've been giving
let's say have had
the effect that they've had is because i
do point out that that's an
extraordinarily common experience
yeah that that that self torture by
conscience and it does
indicate um this striving towards a
higher mode of being
the other question i have when i look at
the
the response that that i just read is
that
the amount of the world's evil that's a
consequence of our voluntary moral
insufficiencies is indeterminate
you know so you might say hypothetically
speaking
that as part of god's creation we
actually have important work to do
and if we shirk it the consequences are
real
and you might say well that's just an
apology for god and perhaps that's the
case and perhaps there's no god at all
and so what the hell are we talking
about but
but i do think it's an important issue i
mean your life is characterized by a
stellar
level of constant productive creativity
that's that that's you and you're
offering that to the world
and that seems necessary and maybe it's
because the problems are real and
important and and the role we have to
play ethically
is of paramount importance truly yeah
why else would we torture ourselves with
conscience and and i would say that's
the flowering of the religious instinct
within you
well you could describe it as that but
then you know there are phrases i mean
you used a phrase earlier then i i
wanted to say whoa hang on i'm not sure
i
know what that means a higher mode of
existence um
i i don't see i remember having this
argument with john cleese of all people
some years ago
he he was a great lover of the
tibetan book of the dead and gilbran and
people like that and
and i've always found them slightly hard
to take
and he talked about a he i think the
phrase he used was a higher level of
consciousness and
i said i don't and again this is my
empiricist thing it sounds cynical and
skeptical it's not meant to be but what
level who's a
what a describer level what is a higher
mode
why higher what's higher than another
are you saying it in terms of animals
um it's a view it's an old-fashioned
huxley in view of
evolution that most modern uh richard
dawkins for example most modern
evolutionary
scientists and and so on the ethologists
would would
deprecate to say that there is a higher
level of being
a higher mode of consciousness is it
just like saying
well you're better educated you've read
more you know more is it you've somehow
been enlightened
a fair clown's effect as the germans
would say which is
um which is not necessarily intellectual
but is somehow spiritual and ah
if so show me an example of it
show me someone who has a higher mode of
existence than i do
uh or the i can i can answer that i
think to some degree
three ways three ways one
that higher mode of existence is what
your conscience tortures you for not
attaining
right okay okay i don't think my
conscience tortures me for not attaining
is that i was rude to someone yesterday
and i shouldn't have been
right but it's the shouldn't part of it
yes the obligation it's the
t exactly david hume is the problem of
ought
yeah well and then you think that you
think you think about how it manifests
itself
you don't this is why nietzsche was
wrong
you cannot create your own values right
the values impose themselves on you
independent of your will
now maybe there you partic well that's
what your conscience does and good luck
trying to control it
this is very anti-nature isn't it it's
well
i'm a great admirer i know you are
that's why i was that's why i made the
point
well opposite to his philosophy but it's
well
so jung embarked on a lengthy critique
of nietzsche and it's part of his work
that isn't well
known i would say but and we'll leave
that be
except to say that the psychoanalysts
starting with freud well not really but
popularized by freud and systematized
showed that we weren't masters in our
own psychological house
nice there were there were autonomous
entities yes and those would be the
greek gods to some degree
that operated within us and we were
which is julian james's point exactly
yes
we're in yes yes i have my problems with
jane's but
as a overarching idea there's interest
in it okay so there are things happening
with us
and to us in the moral domain that we
cannot control yeah
and that's uh that stunned me when i
first learned it as a proposition it's
oh yes look at that
here's one what are you interested in
yeah well that grips you okay
number two what does your conscience
bother you about
okay that's you're inadequate by your
own standards
now what adequate would mean that's a
different
question but it's defined negatively by
conscience yes
and then better there's one that i said
i would lay out three
you can look at jean piaget's work on
developmental psychology the development
of the subject yes
he was a genetic epistemologist he
wanted to do
this is what he wanted to do he wanted
to unite science and religion that was
his goal
and he wanted to look at the empirical
development of values
and what he concluded at least in part
was that a moral stance
that's better than a previous moral
stance does all the things that the
previous moral stance does plus
something else
yes yes and you can say the same thing
no as a scientific theory
i remember i i had a great i i loved
piaget and i
uh his observation was so empirical of
course
yes absolutely the development of the
child and the
uh not quite the theory of mind that
wasn't his thing but but but
similar developments and signposts where
people become aware of self okay so so
now piaget looked specifically at the
development of morality
and he was one of the first people to
emphasize the importance of games
yeah and what he showed what he showed
was that at two years old let's say a
child can only play a game
with him or herself but at three
both children can identify an aim and
then share it in a fictional world and
so that's partly
pretend play and the beginnings of drama
and then cooperate and compete within
that domain
yeah and then what happens and the game
theorists have shown this is that
games out of games morality emerges
yeah there's a result so i'll give you
an example this is a crucial example so
if you pair juvenile rats together the
males
they have to play they have to rough and
tumble play because their prefrontal
cortexes
don't develop properly if they don't
anyways they have to play
you pair a big rat and a little rat
teenage rats together and the big rat
will stomp the little rat
yeah first first encounter so then you
say
power determines hierarchy yeah okay but
then you pair the routes multiple times
like 50 then if the big rat doesn't let
the little rat win
30 of the time the little rat will stop
inviting him to play
and so you get an emergent reciprocity
even at the level of the rat
yeah and it's it's fascinating isn't it
and it's it's not dissimilar to the
theory of
mind uh games that were devised by simon
baron cohen and others
um uh in the question of showing how
neurodivergence um
develops in the autistic spectrum for
example but what one of the things
so interests me at the moment because of
the pandemic
which is slightly close to this that you
might be able to help me with is i've
been very interested in
as i have been over the years at how
completely out of favor
bf skinner and and the behavioralists
have become
uh since i guess since man you probably
don't admire that much
since noam chomsky rather demolished bf
skinner famously
um and on the language front on the
language front
but also the whole nature of
behavioralism and looking at rats and
and their behavior has but
when it came to this pandemic one of the
things that was hidden from the public
was
that every country had its scientific
committees
which were mainly composed of course of
virologists and epidemiologists
and immunologists but always
behaviorologists too
because the secret to getting out of the
pandemic wasn't just
following science and tracking a microbe
an invisible virus in the air it was
how people would take it and
sherlock holmes in the second sherlock
holmes book which is called the sign of
four
says to watson i remember this it's very
interesting he says
you know watson the statistician has
shown
that we can predict to an extraordinary
order of accuracy
the behavior of the average man who uses
the word man where was now we would have
to say human or
man or woman be not i mean the average
man we can
absolutely predict how they will behave
but no one
has yet and probably never will be able
to
to predict how an individual will behave
so we we can be talked about as a mass
and advertisers and politicians and
psyphologists and all kinds of other
people are very good at knowing
how we behave as a group but as
individuals we are
unknowable without face-to-face
conversations in the history and so
on um so that was one and the other one
which i think is connected was
i believe it was a bf skinner experiment
and it's one i absolutely love because
it makes me wonder whether all these
kind of conversations are maybe
ultimately a waste of time but he said
if you take a load of mice and put them
on a
perspex tray and float them on the water
because they are unaware of the risk
they're in
they move around randomly and their
random
movement makes the tray even they're
just randomly moving around
if you scale it up and put humans on it
they sink
within seconds because they think oh
we're tipping we must run to this end
and of course they all run to that end
and so it tips over
in other words consciousness of the
problem attempting to deal with it
being aware of it is the the biggest
problem of all
and that's something new to us because
in the old days we lived in
small groups who just didn't know
how awful humanity was what sins we were
committing
how dreadful we were making the world
it was only through the
telecommunication and through the the
you know the recent
uh development of the global village or
whatever you want to call it
your countryman mcluhan um
that we have actually become aware and
are now likely to be running around in
that tank
and causing it to fall over whereas
really we should just be
unconscious and get on with living and
and
and randomly run about in our tank and
then we'll never sing
does that make sense i want to answer
the behaviors questions
um it's transformed into behavioral
neuroscience and
and and affective neuroscience and being
taken over primarily by the biologists
yeah and part of the reason it's
vanished is because it's become more and
more difficult to do animal experimental
work for all sorts of reasons
and because it requires a tremendous
amount of technical expertise
right so um so that theory of
conditioning has also
vanished with it i know it's transmuted
and become more sophisticated
and been incorporated into all sorts of
theories
the most outstanding behaviorist was
jeffrey gray and he wrote a book called
the neuropsychology of anxiety which is
an absolute work of genius and it's
very heavily influenced by the
schenerian tradition right
um so um i i want to tie something back
again and i've been poking you about
this
and i don't want to stop yet back to um
the distinction between you and and um
dawkins you're
because i see you as a border figure you
you've got one foot in
the the rationalist human rationalist
humanist
atheist um empiricist world firmly
planted but then there's the artist in
you
which is a major part of your
personality
and and and and obviously a part that's
incredibly productive and very well
received
and that has an intellectual end and as
well
the that domain that second domain
that you occupy
isn't formalized the investigation of
that isn't formalized as well by the
atheist community oh you're right
they lose what's there and they don't
value it properly
and they and that's a that's a problem
like with dawkins for example
i i get letters from lots of people lots
and lots of people
and lots of them are nihilistic and
because they're nihilistic they're
suicidal
i had a friend i went for a walk with
him the other week and he was a
communist
atheist when he was a kid he grew up in
poland and he had criticized his family
for celebrating christmas
because it was irrational and then he
realized at one point he said i could
kill christmas and we'd just have
another week
weekend that wouldn't actually right
right
because right there's a magic there
that that rationalism can destroy yeah
and and and
exactly that problem politically with
the royal family which on the face of it
is of course preposterous more
preposterous even than christmas
and religion is the idea that we still
have a royal family
but my belief in
ceremony and ritual and symbolism is i
look at america and i think if only
donald trump and and now
uh biden if every week they had to walk
up the hill and go into a mansion in
washington
and there was uncle sam in a top hat and
striped trousers
a living embodiment of their nation more
important than they were that's the key
he
uncle sam is america the president is a
fly-by-night politician
voted for by less than half the
population and he has to bow
in front of this personification of his
country
every week and that personification
uncle sam can't tell him what to do
uncle sam can't say no pass this act and
don't pass that act and
uh free these people give them a pardon
all he can do is say tell me young fella
what you done this week and he'll bow
and say well uncle sam say oh you think
that's the right thing for my country
well that's what a constitutional
monarchy is and
um of course it's absurd but the fact
that churchill and
thatcher and everyone had to bow every
week in front of this something
there's something and also empirically
look at the happiest countries in the
world
that's all you need do and they happen
to be constitutional monarchies
norway sweden benelux japan they're
always right up there on the list
now it may be that we can't find the
causal link between the constitutional
monarchy but
it might just be something to do with
that and and
and that's it's it's a way of answering
your question in the same with religion
is is that um i i i can see the
absurdities of
the claims of many religions and i can
see the history
of the wickedness and depression and
suppression particularly in my own
instance
uh you know being gay growing up gay and
i there's a long history of religion in
particular being
intolerant and to this day even this
pope francis whom i had some hopes for
it seems to be
beginning to add to an ancient
slander and and nonsensical attitude
towards sexuality which is extremely
annoying
and upsetting but um you know i i kind
of
that doesn't mean i throw the whole baby
out with the bath water i can see
in the same way that i don't believe in
in in greek mythology
in actual fact i don't believe that on
olympus
zeus lived there with his wife hira but
i do believe
hermes and hira and zeus live within us
there is a hermes inside me there is a
there is a trickster a liar a joker
a cute funny side as well as a harmonic
apollonian and a bestial dionysian side
which
is appetitive and addictive and and and
frenzied and
and and i see the value and the
truth in in that in those religious
manifestations those principles those
elements of
of my character and the character of the
human family
in in in mesopotamia the the the god who
became supreme
was marduk he had 50 different names
and one of them was um he who makes
ingenious things
as a consequence of the combat with
tiamat chaos essentially which is a
brilliant
brilliant name but so marduk was the
aggregation
of 50 gods so imagine that each of those
gods was the representative of a tribe
at one point yes
and that would be the value system of
the tribe personified something like
that
and indeed the greek gods derived from
those mesopotamian gods they came here
exactly fundamental uh
what development in the history of
religious thinking and dramatic thinking
well let's say each god is a
manifestation of a value structure
yeah and we say well value structures
have some
commonalities across them just like
games have some commonalities across
them are
or languages have some commonalities
across them so then you start to
aggregate
gods yeah and you produce a metagod and
the metagod is marduk and he's
all eyes because he pays attention like
an empiricist let's say
and speech yeah and so the mesopotamians
had already figured out that attention
and speech were the key elements of
proper sovereignty
yes right brilliant and the egyptians
right they worshipped the
eye same idea and
it was the eye in part that the
egyptians associated with the
immortal soul and they associated that
with the proper local of sovereignty
yeah because they started to abstract
out the idea of sovereignty from the
sovereign
and so the sovereignty could be
something that was now not embodied in
any specific person sort of like
the uncle sam figure that you described
yes wouldn't be the
i often thought with presidents they'd
have a much easier job if the symbolic
weight was lifted from their shoulders
a fourth branch of government right
symbolic ex which is what a
constitutional monarchy exactly is
by accident of history certainly not by
design
but it just somehow the the
the bits of the sovereign that were
inimical
to to human development the the tyranny
the autocracy
the whimsical caprice all these were
sort of chipped away because of the
human failings of different sovereigns
until by 1688
what we call in british history the
glorious revolution when
when the bill of rights was written and
so on which was the same as the american
bill of rights 100 years later
essentially but
and it became a constitutional monarchy
and that was slowly refined as well
and and of course i know many people
find it absurd and outrageous
and they live in palaces and they've got
all this money and it's unjust and of
course all that is true and i wouldn't
defend it on any rational uh uh grounds
but
but i would on empirical grounds okay
okay
and maybe that's a good difference
between rationalism and empiricism
so this uh you were talking about the
gods within
okay and you said well you you believe
that the gods are within and yes
i know that i know i understand the
claim that you're making and
and the limits of that claim but i want
to explore that
okay so as humanity advances
we'll say advancement is the aggregation
of larger societies
our more sophisticated view of the world
more technological power that sort of
thing
more ability to predict and control and
indeed a longer lifetime
yes yes and the things that come along
with that and more peace by the looks of
things and more
food and and the stephen pinker things
right right this exactly that so the
gods aggregate and unify
that happens across as cultures collide
and integrate the gods integrate and
unify
it's the battle between the gods in
heaven
that's the parallel development to the
battle between tribes
for dominance on earth but it's an
integrative process as well as a
submission
process yeah okay so those those are
within yes
now you have an integrated god within
yes
that's what torches you with your
conscience yes
that's your jiminy cricket it's your uh
what philosophy is called your deontic
or deontological uh voice
then then you ask yourself and this is a
dead serious question so imagine that
people are exploring the moral domain
whose reality is blatantly obvious but
but difficult to formalize let's say
we're exploring the
nature of the moral realm tentatively
and we develop more powerful and more
integrated theories as we progress
and you end you end up with a unified
god so it's a monotheism
there's a god within then the question
is well
what exactly is that god within does it
correspond to something that's real
or is it just a figure of the
imagination but then you say well if
it's just a figure of the imagination
what exactly is the imagination
you see christian i think partly
christianity insists that
this integrated god figure
also had a real existence that's that's
how christianity tries to
to solve this particular problem
yes and and people like c.s lewis and
jung to some degree as well would say
well once in history someone acted out
that unified god
so completely that something happened
that's the proposition okay well that's
the limit of the proposition
and then the question is well
how real is this moral striving it's
real enough so you torture yourself
when you don't engage in it properly
it's real enough so you can't avoid its
call
it's real enough so that
you can make moral errors that are so
severe that you can doubt the validity
of your own existence
it's real enough for that
and and this is an honest question it's
like i i don't know
but it's amazing i certainly see how
much good is done when people are good
and how much evil is done when they're
evil yes but it's very hard i think
empirically to
be really boring and use the word again
it's quite you know to build up a list
and show
that there is more morality on the side
of those who followed a particular faith
a particular systematic religion
than than those who didn't uh um i mean
you know that it's okay well that's
really the question
you could certainly have morality
without religion that that is okay
okay let's let's take that for a second
move back to the political
yeah okay because that's the key issue
yes so let's say we're going to defend
the values of the west
to the degree that they're worth
defending then we are making a claim
that the inheritors of a particular
tradition have
something valued valid morally on their
side
or we cannot defend that position
and and we can't defend the position i
mean look i know this is bothering you
what's happening in the broader public
landscape
you got tangled up for example with jk
rowling right
with what's happening around her yeah
and she's a friend and we'll remember
your friend but i'm also
sorry that people are upset you know the
two things are not incompatible
i don't have to break links with jk
rowling to say that i
i have huge sympathy and and i endorse
the efforts of trans people everywhere
to
to live the lives that they they feel
they want to leave a lead and and i hate
how they
they are often you know treated and and
i recognize the courage it takes to
to to yes and you've put your money
where your mouth is on that front
over the course of your whole life i've
tried to yes
yes so it's not just a claim you can
look at your biography and see that
but but but you're disturbed nonetheless
at what's let's say
there's something that's happening in
our culture that's not sitting right
with you okay how do you defend the damn
culture against it
without making the claim that we do have
something of
let's say higher value that is the
consequence of following a particular
tradition
uh yes because without that you lost you
lose the argument
instantly i i mean i think a lot of it
is to do with the
the the necessity that we we all have of
redefining it we have to remember that
morality is is a question of manners it
is
literally what morality means that our
parents and grandparents had a very very
different
and very firm sense of what was immoral
if the word immoral
was used in a newspaper or by a person
then
that person's immoral it would have a
sexual meaning it would mean that they
lived with someone with whom they
weren't married
or they lived with someone of the same
sex or that in some way they they were
philanderers or
loose in their morals meant entirely to
do
with the bedroom these were the
unforgivable behaviors
of a generation that close to us we can
still hug them if we're allowed to in
the garden
in covid times that that's how quickly
morality changes
so the idea of the culture is a false
one there is no
the culture um that there you know it's
not like a human version of a biosphere
even i don't think that there is the
state of things
as now exist but like when when you were
talking about religion and saying this
you know this god that what religion has
been brilliant at and it's
needed to be but so has science is
redefining
what god is what god was in 1400
it was cape god was capable of being
remarkable things
he was answerable for everything and
we worshipped him for it a couple of
hundred years later a few things had
been taken away from him and we could
answer for
travelling the world and knowing it and
discovering how the stars
actually were not holes in a black cloth
but maybe were
celestial objects uh with the you know
and then a few hundred years later
and similarly science we use the word
cosmos well cosmos used to mean
a very small sphere of the the you know
as a section of the
of the of the solar system and now it's
some infinite thing
and there may indeed be dozens of them
millions of them who knows according to
string theory and quantum theory and all
kinds of
schrodinger's number and all the rest of
it that everything is redefined in each
generation
so what is left that is absolute and
this is where religion has an argument
with intellectual progress because
it wants to hang on to something that it
believes is
eternal and and and permanent
and utterly always true but there is no
such thing the morality
you know i mean i did a debate with
christopher hitchens actually
about the catholic church and and the
people defending it
when we attacked the their attitude
towards
child sex scandal said well but in the
1960s it wasn't such a big sin
and what that is actually true
but it's not true coming from a catholic
whose whole point is that they are
eternally true that their morality
is as true now as it was when saint
peter founded the church
that their enemy is people like me who
are relativists
who say that there is no absolute
morality but that things change
according to situation circumstance and
knowledge
and so that is true of
god god alters every day he adds
a little bit of a quality here or she
does and takes away another bit
now no longer responsible for disease
and no longer responsible for
earthquakes but
may be responsible for something else
but it's a shrinking kingdom
and so the idea of there being an
absolute and an eternal
it just doesn't seem to square with the
way we have developed over the
certainly over history which is to say
over the last five thousand years
since we've been able to write things
down before that we
can only judge how and who we were
according to
objects and artifacts and architecture
but since we've been able to write
it's pretty clear that the the
instability of
and and i'm not saying this in a deridar
way of instability of meaning although i
do think you've misunderstood terry
darden
i hope you've read peter salmon's
biography by the way it might change
your mind about him
but that's a whole other subject um but
um
yeah so i'm sorry let's go back okay so
let's go
let's let's go after the eternal
verities yeah
uh idea yeah clearly religious
conceptions shift
although there is there's a core
tradition that remains
intact uh well the tradition by
definition
stays intact there's something that
identifies it as the same entity across
time yes
right maybe that's even mutable but i've
looked for what might be regarded as
eternal verities in the moral domain
so let me put a few forward
um the beautiful is more valuable than
the ugly
yeah truth
truth is to be sought after in
opposition to falsehood
yeah um that's particularly true in
relationship to the spoken word
uh the spoken word brings about
remarkable transformations of reality
itself and
it's for that reason that verbal truth
is
constitutive but also of vital
ethic ethical significance doesn't that
make it all the more important to look
at the discourse beneath
verbal speech to uh to i hesitate to use
the word but to deconstruct it
to or at least to attempt to look
at the currents that run through speech
to see
and they're not all deridarian or you
know the canyon or
foucaultian or whatever the adjective of
foucault is they're not all about power
they're not all
necessarily marxist the the project you
know the so syrian project and the
others of looking at where language
comes from not just in a philological
sense of derivation but in the sense of
where the discourses come from is is
paramount therefore and so to say verbal
you know it's not just an utterance is
in and of itself transformative or if it
is transformative
it might be wickedly so or it might be
negatively so at least
is that not right well with regards to
your point about the analysis of the
of the narratives and even the
deconstruction i would say
it depends on the motive
and it's the motive and this is i
suppose to some degree why i'm
skeptical let's say of the atheist
skepticism
it it's it's destructive there's a
destructive element to it there's not a
there's there's no archaeological
redemption but that's nothing
you said it was all about about that's
not necessarily the case that it has
nothing to do with motive
motive motive's a tough one yeah it is i
mean
my motive is to make money and i make a
great discovery
it's as valuable as if my motive was to
make a great discovery and i made a
great discovery the great discovery is
made
how is the motive relevant
well because your motives determine the
decisions you make along the way
yeah so if i'm fundamentally motivated
by the belief that being
is worth preserving let's say because on
the whole it's a good
i'm going to react and think much
differently than if i'm ambivalent about
that or if i
feel at the bottom of my soul that the
whole bloody project is
of questionable utility and might as
well be shelved
and that that that dichotomy that
characterizes us
you know we have cain and abel
inhabiting us there's no doubt about
that
that's that's a fundamental truth and if
cain has the upper hand
even if it's in the scientific endeavor
the consequences of that
manifest themselves and they manifest
themselves destructively
that's why that's why it's interesting
you have to say cain and abel because i
think this
brings us back to the very beginning is
is the importance of myth and
and also of parable and and i'd like to
end because
we're getting towards a bit where i have
to move away
um but um it
oscar wilde is known as an you know a
master of epigrams and
wit and people mistakenly think of him
as shallow or
trivial or facetious or vain or peacocky
or something but he was very profound in
fact and
of course he could be peacocky too but
um there's a story
that isn't necessarily at odds with no
they said they don't rule each other out
but here's an example of a great parable
um
which is which is why again it's why i
love
literature and and and the art of
of wit because it it zooms to the truth
so much more quickly it seems to me than
so many other attempts to describe or
rationalize truth and
here's one where uh while was at
a at a dinner and uh someone was being
rather kind of uh
envious of someone and being rather
unpleasant and while suddenly said
the devil was walking one day in the
libyan desert
and he saw a monk being
tormented by some of his demons
and he approached and the demons bowed
in front of him and said master and he
said
what goes on here they said master for
39 days and 39 nights we have
tried to tempt this holy monk away from
his god
and his religion but he has stayed
steadfast
and holy to his god and his religion we
have offered
him powers and principalities we've had
offered him the joys
of the flesh we have offered him wine
and food and riches
but he has turned us down there's
nothing that we can do to win
this holy man to our cause and the devil
said
out of my way and he whispered in the
monk's ear
and instantly the monk took the pectoral
cross around his neck and
snapped it and filled the air with
hideous curses against his god and his
church and his religion
and swore he would never follow christ
again
and the demons fell down and in front of
the
the devil and said master what can you
have said in one second that we could
not
what did you say to him and the devil
said oh it was very simple i just told
him his brother had been made bishop of
alexandria
now that seems to me a it's very funny
but b
it is profoundly truthful and it is this
this is the way we show people how
envy and resentment are so much a part
of who we
are that that if you know i mean it
seems like a trivial example but
it just it's a model to me that if you
want
to say something and you want to change
minds and you want
to how to
burn people with the the flame of love
and hope and
connection that we all secretly believe
in them that
you know that makes us gasp when we read
poetry or makes us
feel what love is and joy and all the
things that
we're mostly too embarrassed to talk
about because they're a bit soppy but
truly they matter more than anything
else we displace them on kittens and so
on but we really really
we care about these things and and the
way
i think to to bond people to it is not
to talk
abstractly about ideas necessarily
unless you're talking to someone who has
the same reading as you and that sounds
a snobbish point but unless you're
talking to someone who's also read the
same books or at least
has the same ideas as you e or is open
to them it
just becomes a bit lecturey whereas if
you can tell a story instead
or a parable that's especially if it's
funny or it's sexy or it's
a you know got some quality that just
tickles
you know that strokes us then
then you bring people to to a to a
connection
to to and unfortunately most of the
most of the world who use the art of
rhetoric and persuasion and
and uh do it for nefarious purposes and
maybe that's the key is to try and uh
to try and build up as as you are doing
and i hope i'm doing it my own way
the value of story and um
looking deeply into the nature of
characters within stories that
even though it's just a story it might
actually be a portal
to something really profound that will
touch you and change your life
that's just exactly the right place to
stop
good i'm sorry it has to stop but it's
been one of them three quarters
i knew that we would i was primarily
worried about
this conversation because there were so
many things that i wanted to talk to you
about i didn't know what i would talk to
you about
well i have to have we may have to have
a second one in a few months
yes well after we digest this one yeah
[Music]
you